LeBron just quickly was that was at the
ankle that you caught late and how's it
feeling uh yeah I think I stepped on
some miles mine's foot I think it was
maybe Aaron Gordon to learn to guys up
underneath the basket but I'll be fine
and LeBron what did you feel like when
Deborah was hitting those five straight
threes like what's the differences in
your coverages and what you're trying to
do battling jokic and you know not
letting them get in there versus what
you're giving up on the outside
only one of them was uncontested
the whole album was great contests
um
two of the most threes was right in the
face of me and A.D Michael Porter Jr one
by our bench was right in the face of AR
after a transition they was winning
transition
Bruce Brown had one as well with a
contest
they made I was at the three-point line
is what killed us in the fourth but
I didn't see many breakdowns though
Eddie
um did they do anything different
defensively tonight against you than in
game one and what do you think it'll
take to bounce back in game three
uh no I got the same looks
um a lot of them were just short tonight
oh
not that it's an excuse but you guys
exerted so much energy early both of you
to Pennsylvania Nicola jokicz did you
feel like legs are fatigue factored at
all later
I mean if you're not tired in the
postseason then
everybody's tired
you see there's two teams playing here
you guys playing on one team in the west
and Jamal Murray had a remarkable
performance particularly in the fourth
quarter just what'd you see out of him
and what type of Rhythm was he able to
find against your guys defense
um I mean he makes he made shots he made
shots at the end of the end of the clock
when we gone for 24 seconds he made two
big time shots one over 81 over myself
um had some mid-range game going on but
he had his three-point uh shot going in
the fourth it's not I mean it's no
surprise to anybody's done it before you
know hate to be on the other side of it
but like I said I don't feel like we had
many breakdowns when he was doing what
he was doing he made shots and sometimes
he's just making mislead I feel like
defensively we were we were really good
I mean they shot 43 for number one
offense in the league you know and you
know so it just sucks that you know the
five threes in the fourth of the killers
would you guys make of the the starting
lineup adjustment going back to the
starting lineup you guys have been using
for most of the second half of the
season and just kind of playing bigger
lineups in general tonight I really
don't know it doesn't matter at this
point who starts who comes off the bench
just about how we can get it done and
win a game it's all that matters
LeBron they haven't lost a game at home
in the postseason neither of you guys we
include the plan you have to last you
won the last seven does that give you
guys any more a benefit for you guys
going home knowing you haven't lost the
game no I mean we still got to play with
the same desperation as we did tonight I
mean we came out with a l but
it doesn't give us any more Comfort we
can't go into any postseason game with
Comfort uh just because you either
haven't lost at home or you're going
back home I think it's even more you got
to be on edge because when you go home
you're getting your own bed you run your
family everybody's being cool and you
know jolly and everything nah you got to
be even more on edge when you get home
so you know we got to understand that
going back and being downhill too
there's no reason for us to get
comfortable Brown after these two game
two games what do you think do you need
to improve and keep doing now that you
are going home
um I think we improved from game one to
game two
um and if we can do the same thing from
game two to game three we'll put itself
in a position to win
from a mental emotional standpoint what
what do you take out of that that can be
applied if anything
I mean what do you take out of it is the
fact that um this is not the NCAA
tournament and it's a first team to four
wins and uh we have an opportunity to go
home and play great basketball and home
serve so
um you know until the team beats you uh
four times then you always have an
opportunity to come out of it you know
so that that's the confidence that we
should have and I know it's going to be
a it's a tough Hill to climb up but we
still have an opportunity to you know
play good basketball and and play the
best basketball of the series in game
three and like I said if we can get
better from game two like we did
tonight's a game three then we put
ourselves in a position to do that day
Eddie you made the one three and then
you had the two other looks there um
what'd you think about those shots that
you got down the stretch and just
overall
um you're coming off 40 your efficiency
wasn't there the way it was in game one
uh I like both of the looks
um
made the first second one was back rim
and the next one the same as Xbox Ram's
in and out so like all the looks that I
got today
um just a lot of short
um now I'm going to continue to shoot
those shots and so I gotta be better
more efficient
um help the team win so
I'll be back uh whatever
LeBron
um the dunk in the first half is not a
play we often see
um the ball squirts out like that there
was another play I think in the third
where you guys got an offensive Rebound
in Dennis could have helped for one he
shoots
um when the margins are so slim are
those the plays that kind of eat at you
um between now and game three
no I mean those are
you know obviously you have an
opportunity I mean
my my opportunity puts us up 10.
um and instead we it was an eight-point
you know deficit in the good for us
um you know obviously that's
sucks that that ball squared out of my
hand like that whatever the case would
be maybe hit my knee or whatever but uh
unforce unforced turnover by myself
horrible especially on the road and I
mean the same thing at the end of the
third um you know I miss a three I
believe we were up five I missed a three
um Jamal Murray try to save it saves it
right to 80 and we swing into AR and
Dennis had a pretty good look but we had
an opportunity to hold and not take the
shot with a five-point lead and instead
they get the block Bruce Brown get the
block
um Joker pushes it throws it to the
right corner away from our bench kcp we
get a great contest on kcp from AR
and I thought it was I thought it was a
great block by 80 to be completely
honest but they call go 10 and instead
of being a five we have up three so I
was a momentum plays for sure both of
them